while health officials are concerned
about that potential surge in infections
congressional negotiations over a
federal coronavirus relief bill
are still in limbo so joining us for
more on that is republican kentucky
congressman and ranking member of the
house oversight committee
james comer congressman thank you so
much i mean you just saw in that report
from christina coleman
that restaurant over crying saying he's
going to lose his business over a lot of
these coveted restrictions but
congress could help people like him
small business owners like him if they
just passed another
stimulus bill do you think another
stimulus bill is necessary and if so
how soon can these americans and small
business owners
how long will it take for them to get
just a little bit of relief
well i think another stimulus bill is
necessary but this one needs to be
targeted
the last bill was a blanket bill when it
was passed
we had no idea how serious the cobit
pandemic would be we didn't know
which businesses would be hurt the most
we just assumed every business would be
heard at the same level
and we passed that uh cares act and it
made a difference and the ppp loan
program was probably one of the most
successful
emergency loan programs in the history
of america moving forward to the second
stimulus bill
we need to have targeted stimulus the
restaurant industry i think that's the
one industry that there's bipartisan
agreement
that there is a desperate need for
assistance but we have a situation in
washington we're nancy pelosi
she doesn't want to do targeted stimulus
she wants to do another blanket stimulus
bill
and give money to everyone and forgive
student loan debt and just a liberal
christmas wish list that's just not
going to happen because we just can't
afford it congressman really quick i
think so many americans are so focused
on just timing and you look
at uh that lower third that was just on
your screen saying that the last
stimulus bill was passed
way back on march 27th i mean in terms
of timing
is it safe to say that any stimulus
relief
would have to come in the next congress
that it is dead in this lame duck
session
i think the odds of passing another
stimulus in this lame duck session are
slim
but i want to remind people that there's
still funds that haven't been
appropriated from the last stimulus bill
three trillion dollars is a lot of money
and we finished this year with about a
four trillion dollar budget
deficit that's unsustainable but we do
need to help
businesses in need you know a
frustration for a lot of republicans in
congress is
that restaurant owner was in california
with the democrat governor we have
kentucky with the same restrictions
with the democrat governor my district's
down the tennessee state line
yesterday i saw on facebook a huge
percentage of my district
traveled south to tennessee where they
don't have those restrictions
to eat and to go christmas shopping and
there's
a big difference between how the
democrat governors have run their states
and the burdens and regulations they put
on businesses versus
how the republicans have run the state
so we should never have a situation
where the government
forces businesses like restaurants to
shut down that's
unconstitutional it's un-american
congressman i want to ask you about
these
extended federal unemployment benefits
because in kentucky they expire
today and about 4 000 people in your
state are currently relying on those
extended benefits i understand that that
is happening because it's triggered by
the state's unemployment rate falling
below a certain threshold but is there
anything you can do what is your message
to those
4 000 people in kentucky who are going
to lose their benefits those extended
benefits today
well kentucky is still going to have
unemployment that's
one of the things that i think it's lost
in translation they'll still be drawing
unemployment it's just the above and
beyond unemployment
a lot of our employers in the district
have been very upset
with the enhanced unemployment they feel
like that's led to a higher unemployment
rate because
a lot of people unfortunately
have made as much or in some cases more
money drawing extended unemployment so
we've got to get unemployment under
control in kentucky
we have an unemployment bureaucracy
that's helped
that's prevented people that deserve to
be unemployed and drawing unemployment
insurance from getting unemployment and
some that have just
abused their unemployment because there
are a lot of problems with unemployment
but the reason that we have a high
unemployment rate is because our
governor shuts our state down
you know i wish kentucky was operated
more like south dakota with governor
noam or florida with governor desantis
well coach
yes but there's also a pandemic going on
i mean states across the country are
dealing with these
uh unemployment numbers congressman
thank you so much and best of luck
getting this pandemic under control
in your state thank you for having me
you bet